bernard verront bonjour et merci d'être
en direct avec nous ce matin lors de
l'aveu même de l'onu
c'est un triste record qu'était a été
atteint au sahel un chiffre qui reflète
la réalité selon vous oui absolument il
ya beaucoup de violence dans les pays du
sahel d'ailleurs une violente de
plusieurs d'origine il y a bien
évidemment ce qu'on appelle une sorte de
guerre d'une part et d'autre part il ya
des tensions entre les communautés
notamment entre les communautés de
pasteurs nomades et et d'agriculteurs
sédentaires et j'étais différent du co
se mêlent les unes les autres explique
explique en effet ce déferlement d'eau
populations réfugiées quand tu as chanté
voilà des violences donc un cercle
infernal de violences quelques deux
millions de personnes déplacées ce que
on doit s'attendre à une aggravation de
la situation avec la pandémie
kovy 19 mais malheureusement la pandémie
de 2009 ne peut qu'aggraver la situation
notamment parmi les personnes déplacées
qui vivent de façon extrêmement précaire
avec un suivi sanitaire pour le moins
des fanions comment est ce que les
gouvernements font face à cette crise et
ont-ils les moyens de la gérer alors
pour l'instant cette crise n'est pas
gérée n'est pas correctement géré lit
par les gouvernements locaux unis par
les appuis internationaux qui leur sont
qui leur sont qui leur sont apportés et
c'est difficile de prédire quelle bête
l'évolution dans les prochaines semaines
dans les prochains mois alors ce bilan
de l'onu intervient à quelques jours
alors que
après la prise de parole des manuels
macron qui envisageait de réduire la
force marcano au sahel alors si la
france réajuste ses effectifs quelles
conséquences sur les populations
écoutez la position de la france
consiste en effet à était de réduire la
position au sahel ne pas oublier que la
france n'est présent que dans la région
sahélienne depuis le depuis début
octobre il y avait donc huit ans
maintenant et la situation sécuritaire
ne s'est pas améliorée au contraire dans
la région du liptako gourma entre le
mali le burkina faso le niger elle s'est
fortement aggravée et la france et c'est
d'une part de ge à prendre le relais par
une porte dont l'europe est d'à coups
bas mais ils sont très peu nombreux même
si une force d'élite et d'autre part par
un renforcement des armées locales
mais cela ne peut pas se faire du jour
au lendemain comment on pourrait réagir
la communauté internationale pour venir
en aide justement à ces peuples du sahel
écoutez alors il ya deux types d'elle il
ya bien évidemment une aide apportée aux
personnes de tes places 2 millions de
personnes déplacées identification
extrêmement difficile et d'autre part il
faut conforter la capacité des pays à
faire face à l'insécurité ce qui se pose
pour le moins d'une part de renforcer
les forces de sécurité en question et
d'autre part d'améliorer la gouvernance
de thé pays du sahel dont les chez
blaise sont une des causes
vraisemblablement de la montée de la
confidentialité
la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest la cédéao at elle
un rôle à jouer écouter alors la cedeao
se positionner dans le cas de crise
d'une part dans le cas du mali après que
le président eut pekka himanen boubacar
keita et été renversé par un coup d'état
militaire dans un premier temps une
position dure envisageant même de mettre
le mail sous sanction et puis finalement
une position puisqu'ils à doucier en
disant écoutez simulation dans un relais
par une force non un gouvernement civil
ça ira
d'une part et d'autre part en suisse à
chi de la côte d'ivoire alors c'est pas
ça et c'est juste en dessous l'élection
de sl ouattara a soulevé en effet des
tensions notamment avec laurent gbagbo
hélas la cde a dit écoutez dans cette
élection
le correct il faut les respecter donc
elle est positionnée j'ai ensuite eu
qu'à la trêve est en tout cas merci
beaucoup jean-bernard aveyron d'être
intervenu ce matin sur notre antenne je
rappelle que vous êtes le rédacteur en
chef de la revue afrique contemporaine